今から日本語のレッスンを行います。
「外人ハンター」
「外人ハンターとは単純に言うと外国人が好きな日本人のこと」
「日本には外人ハンターが非常に多い」
…らしい。
なら、こうしてみよう。
僕が日本で知らない日本人女性に話し掛けられた数はいくらだと思う？
はい、
ゼロです。
一度もないです。
一方、
僕がアメリカで日本人女性に話し掛けられた数？
これも一度もないです。
じゃあ、
僕がアメリカで白人女性に話し掛けられた数はいくらだと思う？
ゼロです。
ならば、
僕がアメリカで知らない白人男性に話し掛けられた数はいくらだと思う？
ゼロです。
で、何を言おうとしたっけ？
「あっ、アイスコーヒーお願いします」
「あぁ、ちょっと待ってください…」
「すぐに英語が出来るスタッフをお呼びしますので」
「いや、日本語で話してますけど……」
「アイスコーヒーお願いします」
"Yeah no problem."
"So are you travelling in Japan right now?"
"Uh no, I actually live here."
「因みに日本語も出来ーー」
"Oh yeah?"
"Where are you originally from?"
"Oh, well, I was born in Califor—"
"Yeah… I lived in America for a few years during high school."
"Michigan, actually."
"I've actually never—"
"Had a REAL hard time readjusting back to live in Japan."
"I mean, you know what it's like.  People who've never been to the States -- they don't get it."
「いや、あのう、コーヒーお願——」
"I don't even know what my identity is."
"Am I Japanese?"
"Am I American?"
「あぁ——」
"I mean, what's my place in society?"
"God, I miss the States…"
「アイスコーヒーお願いします」
"No problem. Anything else?"
「ふーん。僕は今、日本語で話しましたよね」
「なのに、あなたは英語で返事をしました」
「あっ、そっか。失礼しました」
「うーん。これは問題ですね」
「僕は英語が出来なかったらどうしますか？」
「これは差別なんですよ」
「人種差別なんですよ」
「はい、マネジャーを呼んでください」
「ボクのニホンゴはあなたの英語ヨリ上手デす」
「アイスコーヒーお願いします」
「みせのなかで」
「のみますか？」
「あっ、アイスコーヒーお願いします」
「アイスコーヒーですね」
「店内でお召し上がりですか？」
「あっ、そうです」
「かしこまりました。350円です」
「あっ、こんにちは。在留カードを更新したいんですけど…」
「あ、パスポートと住所が記載されているものを持参してください」
「あと、更新の申請書も出してください」
「あと、更新の申請書——」
「あと、身元保証書、」
「課税証明書、」
「納税証明書、」
「も持ってきてください」
「あぁ、分かりました」
「まず、どこ行ったらいいですか？」
「まずは職場に行ってください」
「あ、こんにちは。『身元保証書』をもらいに来たんですけど」
「あぁ、はい。まずは目薬をもらってきてください」
「うん？　目薬……ですか？」
「この処方箋を東事務所の方に渡してください」
「あぁ……　わ、分かりました」
「あっ、こんにちは。ここに来たら目薬をもらえるって聞いたんですけど」
「薬の原料ならここにありますけど」
「ハイラル湖の博士にこれを渡してください」
「これは新鮮のうちに届けないと」
「これは目玉蛙ではないっか？」
「今夜は久しぶりに目玉——」
「えっ？　『薬』となぁ？」
「さぁ、出来た！」
「しかし、この温度ではこの薬は——」
「しみるゴロー！」
「はい。えぇっと、」
「道元さん」
「お待たせしました」
「えっ！」
「また１年間かよ！？」